هل يمكننا ان نقول بان هذا سنعكس سلبا على
على الديمقراطيين في الانتخابات النصفيه
نحن نتوقع موجه اكتساح حمراء في
الانتخابات النصفيه
فالناخبوا الان يجد نفسه يتعامل مع العديد
من الظروف التي هي نتائج اداره جو بارد
وحزبه الديمقراطي فاولا يتعامل المستهلك
الامريكي مع اسعار وقود مرتفعه جدا وتذكر
ان الناس هنا يحتاجون لقياده سيارتهم من
اجل الوصول لمقارات اعمالهم ولذلك فان
الامريكي اصبح يتساءل عما اذا كان يتعين
عليه الدفعه من اجل الوصول الى مقر عمله
او الدفعه من اجل اطعام اطفاله هذا قرار
صعب ومهم وخطير ويومي امام المستهلك
الامريكي هذا فضلا عن مستويات التضخم
وارتفاع نسبه الجريمه في البلاد وفي جميع
هذه الميادين سياسه الجمهوريين هي الافضل
بل انها نقاط قوتهم وهناك قناعه لدى
الكثيرين الان بانه لو كانت هناك اداره
جمهوريه حاليا في البيت الابيض ما كان
لازمه طاقه انت تضرب البلاد وما كان لنا
ان نبعد ابرز خلفائنا التقليديين المهمين
وفي المملكه العربيه السعوديه وانا مقتنعه
بالمناسبه ان وعندما يستعيد الجمهوريين
رئاسه البلاد عام 2024 ستستعيد العلاقات
بين الرياض واشنطن مستواها التاريخيه
التقليدي وبسرعه والناخبون الامريكيون
العاديون تاكدوا الان ان اخطاء الحزب
الديمقراطي هي التي طلبت معها حياتهم وان
الجمهوريين هم الاقدر وهم الممثلون الاقرب
لهم بفعاليه سياساتهم الامنيه وما يتعلق
بالتضخم والطاقه وملفات التعليم وغيرها
ولذلك نحن متاكدونا من ان البلاد ستشهد
اكتساحا للجمهوريين في الانتخابات المقبله
حيث نرجح الفوز بالاغلبيه وذلك في انتظار
الفوز بالبيت الابيض علما ان كثيرا من
الجمهوريين سيطرون على منصب الحاكم في عده
ولايات